wasn't there a story of your parents
waiting in line to get your autograph
they've been to every Olympia and they
go to the athlete meet greet and they
waited for like an hour in line or
something what the are you doing
Mom I'm like we don't want to bother you
we just want to just want a picture I'm
like well you're a VIP you can come
backstage you can do whatever you want
here that's the humility that they
raised to me though you know they never
expect anything and they're just always
quietly there in the background support
me I wonder whether part of that
humility is maybe where you're not
wanting to lean on other people comes
from I do think it's part of it for sure
and I mean my dad is still like my
number one role model but he didn't ask
for help even if he wanted to do
something with me he wouldn't like
building a fence you'd have to be like
hey Dad do you want me to help and he
like loved that but he wouldn't have
asked and I'm like how the did you
do that for so long have you ever asked
him about it I have and now that I've
gotten to this age I've like gone to him
I'm like do you ever like feel like an
exploding and he's like not really no
and I'm like what the they made him
different man they made him different in
the series I had to really learn that
that's not normal that's not me and I
had to accept that that's what was
definitely part of the journey